[Music]
on this wednesday night alberta's
fast-paced plan to reopen
it means the best alberta summer ever
the details
the backlash and the impact on the
greatest outdoor show on earth
pandemic response failures the auditor
general on how ottawa dropped the ball
while the british prime minister's
former advisor delivers a scathing
review
of the uk pandemic plan this is like a
scene
from independence day with jeff goldblum
saying the aliens are here and your
whole plan is broken
going with the grain it's becoming a
really
sexy proposition for many farmers
oat milk's rise to the cream of the crop
of dairy alternatives
and to the moon canada's plan for
lunar exploration
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
another province has laid out plans for
easing covid19 restrictions
alberta which only a few weeks ago had
canada's highest number of active
infections
now has the fastest reopening plan in
the country
premier jason kenney says if enough
people get vaccinated
all restrictions could be lifted by
early july
just in time for the calgary stampede
today we are truly near the end of this
thing
we're leaving the darkest days of the
pandemic behind and stepping into the
warm light of summer
like other provincial reopening plans
alberta's three-step strategy is linked
to vaccinations
premier kenny calls his approach
cautious but he's already getting
pushback from others who fear it's too
much
too fast heather yorick's west has the
details and the reaction
in our top story tonight it was one week
ago that alberta health services warned
intensive care units in the province
were busier than they've ever
been alberta's third wave hit hard but
with cases now beginning to fall
the province is looking aggressively
towards opening
back up in short it means that finally
getting back to normal and i think it
means the best alberta
summer ever part of those summer plans
include the calgary stampede
while other cities have already canceled
events like toronto's cne
there are plans to hold a rodeo and
midway here
in just over a month's time conklin is
coming as i understand it for the midway
the
cowboys are coming for the rodeo
i'm sure the young canadians and and all
of the local performers are are geared
up
alberta is betting on a single dose
summer being enough to get the province
back to normal in a hurry
on june 1st people can gather in groups
of up to 10
outdoors patios and hair salons can
reopen
and outdoor sports and performances with
up to 10 people can resume
two weeks after 60 percent have one dose
outdoor social gathering limits move to
20 people
indoor dining resumes gyms movie
theaters youth sports and day
camps open and large events like
concerts and festivals will also be
permitted
with up to 150 people after 70 percent
of albertans are vaccinated projected
for early july
all further restrictions will be lifted
alberta's former
chief medical health officer worries
it's too much too soon
yes it's setting it up for a fourth wave
the science is pretty clear that the new
indian variant will be 1.617
in people who only had a single dose is
quite uh good at infecting them again
you really need two doses to get good
protection this does not look like an
evidence-based plan it looks like the
premier is working backwards from the
stampede
there won't be a parade kicking off the
stampede the premier says the city of
calgary won't be issuing a permit for
that
but after 15 months of restrictions the
rise and rodeo
are a go whether that kicks off the best
summer ever
we will see heather urex west global
news calgary
in manitoba hospitals are still
scrambling to keep up with all the
people becoming critically ill with
covid19
23 manitobans have already been
airlifted to hospitals in ontario
more are expected to be transferred
later today and as a sign of just how
sick these patients are the province
says one person who was about to be
transferred to ontario
earlier this week died before takeoff
newfoundland and labrador has confirmed
a growing cluster of coveted cases there
is caused by the b16172
variant that's the one first detected in
india there are now
46 active cases in central newfoundland
and much of that region
is in partial lockdown this variant is
more easily transmissible than the
original strain of covet
and reports have also indicated it may
be more transmissible than b117
dr janice fitzgerald says confirmation
of the variant won't alter that
province's vaccine rollout
55 percent of the eligible population
has received at least one
vaccine dose the decline in case numbers
in ontario has given
hope for a return to in-classroom
learning before school's out for the
summer
while some parents want their children
to have the opportunity to go back
others believe it only makes sense to
keep them home
to avoid any new outbreaks as eric
sorenson explains with just weeks left
in this school year
it's crunch time for the ontario
government to come up with a plan
this is a pivotal moment for rebecca
steinhoff's children and two million
ontario students from kindergarten
to grade 12. will they go back to
classrooms before the school year is out
or not they've been learning from home
since april 19th
rebecca wants her three school-aged kids
back in the classroom as soon as
possible
my kids are really just missing their
friends missing school
they're disengaging from online learning
i think they need
that kind of closure that going back
would give them it's a race against time
to get coveted numbers down enough to
reopen the schools
before they close again for the summer
ontario's chief medical officer of
health is pushing for it
i've been encouraging schools to open as
soon as possible
most ontario health districts now have
very low rates of covid
even the two ontario regions inundated
with cases toronto and peel
have seen case numbers drop by
two-thirds in the last three weeks
schools should be the last to close in
the first to open other parents though
prefer to keep their children learning
from home
kyla harrington works from home so it's
convenient and she thinks it's safer and
a pandemic
my instinct was to keep my kids home i
went straight to safety
i knew my son with asthma my kids are
grade 3 grade 6 and grade 8
so they're they're more independent and
so they can handle
the responsibility some doctors believe
kids should not be hurried back into
classrooms
when covet variants can still spread
easily will there be outbreaks
yeah i'm sure there will be outbreaks
and so to have a child go back to school
and only to have that school close again
i think
that's very hard we have some differing
opinions
ontario's premier is being pressed to
make a decision as early as this week
schools can reopen with care says this
infectious disease specialist that
really does meet you know lower class
sizes
open windows a lot more outdoor use of
classrooms
if you can make an achievable plan based
on that i think it's reasonable
some parents feel so much was lost in
the last year that their children
should be allowed to repeat their year
shaunice jackson's child has special
needs
she doesn't really feel like she's
learning the way that she should be
learning
trying to repeat grade six she's ready
to she wants to
but there can also be adverse effects
from youngsters separating from their
familiar cohorts
there are no easy answers my kids you
know ask me every day are we going to go
back are we going to
see your friends for the last month of
school rebecca steinhoff wants her kids
back in school
but also just wants a decision to be
made eric sorensen global news
toronto some good news about vaccines
among canada's indigenous population
indigenous services minister mark miller
says 75 percent of adults in first
nations
metis and inuit communities have now
received at least one dose
in canada's non-indigenous population 53
percent of people have had one dose
since the vaccine rollout ramped up in
january active case numbers in first
nations communities have dropped by more
than 85 percent
as of yesterday the federal government
was aware of 741
active cases in first nations
communities on reserves
the federal government is getting just a
passing grade for its handling of the
personal protective equipment issue in
the first weeks of the pandemic
canada's auditor general says when the
pressure mounted the government quickly
acquired seven billion dollars worth of
desperately needed ppe and medical
devices
but as david aiken reports it failed to
address
long-standing issues with the national
stockpile of ppe
the first wave the pandemic last spring
was quickly followed by a frantic hunt
for shields
masks gowns and other personal
protective equipment or
ppe there is insufficient
number of ventilators and an inadequate
supply of
personal protective equipment across the
country there is a
definite you know lack of supply of
being able to get things like
masks gloves other things like that
but then after what the auditor general
on wednesday called an
unprecedented government response to the
crisis
millions of pieces of ppe started to
ship to front line workers
what we did see was that the government
was quite reactive and flexible
and we did see health canada and the
public health agency as well as public
service and procurement canada
come together and collaborate still
canada would not have had to scramble
the way it did
if the federal government had maintained
its reserve of
ppe and medicine we found that before
the pandemic
the public health agency of canada had
not addressed
long-standing known issues with the
systems and practices
used to manage the national emergency
strategic stockpile
and those issues still have not been
addressed today
in the meantime the government's focus
has been on building
more domestic capacity to manufacture
ppe indeed just today alone
ottawa handed out about seven million
dollars to manufacturers
in alberta ontario and quebec all aimed
at developing and building
the next generation of ppe and medical
devices
don all right david aiken in ottawa
thanks
tens of thousands of people died who
didn't need to die
when the public needed us most the
government failed
and i'd like to say to all the families
of those who
died necessarily how sorry i am for the
mistakes that were made and for my own
mistakes of that
that is dominic cummings the former top
adviser to british prime minister boris
johnson
he has turned on his former boss who he
now calls
unfit for the job he says johnson's
handling of the pandemic has been
chaotic
he accuses johnson of making constant
u-turns
like a shopping trolley smashing from
one side of the aisle to the other
crystal commansing on the scathing
testimony from the man
who helped get boris johnson elected
the truth is that senior ministers
senior officials senior advisers like me
fell disastrously short unfiltered
unpopular
and before a commons committee dominic
cummings was
unwavering in his condemnation of the uk
government's response to the pandemic
it's completely crackers that someone
like me should have been in there just
the same as
crack as the boris johnson was in there
cummings had no choice but to paint
himself with the same critical brush
until late 2020 he was in the
government's inner circle
helping to craft the uk's covet 19
strategy
cummings told mps the health secretary
should have been fired on multiple
occasions
and that prime minister boris johnson
didn't grasp the gravity of the pandemic
there's a great misunderstanding people
have that because it nearly
killed him therefore he must have taken
it seriously while cummings outlined the
failings of the government
his former boss was facing questions in
parliament
i don't think anybody could credibly
accuse this government of being
complacent about the threat that this
virus posed
at any at any point we have worked flat
out
mr speaker but more questions are being
raised and more evidence will be given
as parliament's health
sciences and technology committees
investigate britain's pandemic response
more than 127 thousand people have died
from covid19 so far
an independent inquiry into the
government's handling of the crisis
begins next year crystal gomanson global
news
london india now hit
by a cyclone coming up the natural
disaster happening on top of the covid
disaster
plus a site not seen in three thousand
years
this is the last thing india needs right
now cyclone yaz
slammed into the country's east coast
this morning more than a million people
were forced to flee their homes
a huge tidal surge has turned roads into
rivers and homes
to rubble at least six people are known
to have died
in the storm police in italy have
arrested three people after that cable
car plunged to the ground and killed 14
people
officers say a clamp was used to
intentionally deactivate the emergency
brake on the cable car
it failed to engage when the main cable
snapped the cable car plunged to the
ground and rolled down a steep hill
prosecutors believe the move was a stop
gap measure to avoid shutting down the
attraction for extensive repairs
criminal charges are being considered a
five-year-old boy is the only survivor
he is recovering in the hospital
for the first time in three thousand
years tasmanian
devils are officially back and breeding
on mainland australia
seven tiny joeys were born at this
wildlife sanctuary near sydney
the team from aussie arc has been
working for 10 years to reintroduce the
endangered marsupial to the mainland
they died out on mainland australia
after the arrival
of dingoes
the struggle to answer one of the
biggest questions of the pandemic
still ahead where did covid come from
there is still no certainty about the
origins of the novel coronavirus
and now the theory that it may have been
an accidental leak from a lab in wuhan
china is gaining traction
u.s president joe biden has ordered an
intelligence review of the possible
scenarios
jackson proskow explains what's
triggered this and why it's so important
to find the answer
that's it one year later there are
treatments and vaccines
but the most perplexing question of the
pandemic remains unanswered
where did the virus come from we've lost
almost 600 000
americans to cover 19 and we have to get
a better sense
of the origin of cover 19. there are two
competing theories both
centered in wuhan china either that the
virus crossed over from infected animals
to humans
or that it escaped from a high level lab
in the city by accident
many of us feel that it is more likely
that this is a natural occurrence
because we don't know 100
what the origin is it's imperative that
we look and we do an investigation
the lab leak theory gained steam after a
u.s intelligence report claimed
three researchers from the wuhan lab
were treated in hospital for covet-like
symptoms in november 2019
a month before the first reported cases
of the virus
china has denied the possibility state
media calls it a conspiracy theory
nobody knows because we don't have the
data we haven't had
the kind of investigation that we need
to really understand it
the biden administration has ordered a
detailed intelligence report in the next
90 days
while the u.s wants the world health
organization to launch a second
independent investigation
accusing china of not being fully
transparent and give
international experts the independence
to fully assess the source of the virus
and the early days of the outbreak yet
biden's team is wary of comparisons to
the trump administration
which pushed the lab theory and allowed
conspiracy theories to flourish
and there is significant evidence that
this came from the laboratory
scientists say it's not about laying
blame but answers are important
it's about the origin of this virus and
being able to prevent
future pandemics before they start that
could help contain future outbreaks or
prevent
future mistakes it won't bring back all
that's been lost
or stop the virus that's still raging
around the world
jackson prosko global news washington
got grain next the growing demand for
milk alternatives
the duke and duchess of cambridge have
gone back to their university days in
scotland they went head to head in a
land yachting race at st
andrews where they met and fell in love
20 years ago the royal couple
raced in wind powered go-karts organized
by a charity that helps teenagers who
care for family members
at one point kate's back wheel was
lifted up by the force of the wind
and prince williamwell he claimed he won
there are all kinds of options these
days if you don't or
can't drink cow's milk there's milk made
from soy from
almonds and from oats oat milk has
actually been around for decades but
now it's really taken off and become a
multi-billion dollar product
mike trolley explains why oat milk is
no booming oat milk marketing has
targeted
a certain demographic it's for the next
gen my gen
more specifically gen zed and
millennials and those generations are
not only listening
they've made oat milk the health fad of
the year
oatley the swedish based company that
made milking a note cool
went public last week with a valuation
of 10 billion
u.s numbers like that don't mean much in
coffee shops
here at toronto's wallace espresso it's
all about taste
they steam up really closely to the way
dairy does daniel wallen says his oat
milk orders
have risen sharply over the past three
years and now eclipse soy and almond
as the alternative of choice but the
other thing with oat milk is because i
feel it's so close to dairy milk in
flavor
and texture it's reached a broader
audience it's the same audience that fed
into the plant-based burger boom of
2019.
health is an issue for them but so too
is the environment and oat milk uses far
less land
and has fewer greenhouse gas emissions
than dairy it also takes 628 liters of
water to produce one liter of milk
compared with 371 liters for a liter of
almond milk
and 48 liters for oat milk i think it's
a great
alternative right now until something
else comes along
we've had all sorts of milk that haven't
really stuck but if you think about hemp
milk
it does not taste good so if there's a
product on the market that tastes good
you can put it in your coffee you can
put it on your cereal and it doesn't
feel like you're hard done by
then i think it's more likely to stick
oat milk certainly checks all those
boxes
and that's bringing smiles to canadian
farmers who produce more oats than
anywhere outside the european union an
oat
is certainly growing it was really
kind of the forgotten child in the
prairies for a very long time but
now it's becoming a really sexy
proposition for many farmers sexy
oats why not mike droli global news
toronto
some exciting plans for lunar
exploration were revealed today the
canadian government has put out a
request for proposals to build a robotic
vehicle that could end up
on the moon within the next five years
canada plans to land a lunar rover
on the moon that's the big news today
to achieve that objective the canadian
space agency will be looking for two
canadian companies
to develop concepts for the rover and
science
instruments for the mission
it will have to make it through the
extreme cold and dark of a lunar night
which lasts about two weeks
just the job for canada right there was
just another rare lunar event that
required
less expertise it's called the super
flower blood moon and it was the only
total
lunar eclipse in 2021 it was visible on
the west coast in the early morning
hours
it's a super moon because it's full when
it's at its closest point to the earth
the blood is from the red color that's
the result of the lunar eclipse
and the flower is what a full moon is
called in may
that's global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]